oui
[Musique]
il ne reste peut-être pas plus de
quarante-huit heures avant que le
gouvernement britannique de boris
johnson publie son analyse complète de
sa politique étrangère
alors que les militants contre les
ventes d'armes à l'arabie saoudite
espèrent un changement dans ce qui est
des facs de l'ingérence britannique au
yémen où sévit la pire crise humanitaire
du monde dans quelques instants nous en
parlerons avec la capitale saoudienne
mais nous recevons d'abord dans notre
émission brian fogle réalisateur
oscarisé dont le nouveau film nominé aux
bafta the dissidentes nous fournit de
nouvelles preuves sur le meurtre du
journaliste du washington post jamal
khashoggi brian merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous pourquoi avoir décidé
d'aborder le sujet de l'assassinât du
journaliste du washington post
après votre fille mikari qui a remporté
un oscar vous savez comme une grande
partie du monde durant les quelques
semaines qui ont suivi le meurtre de
jamal khashoggi en octobre 2018 j'étais
sous le choc
consternée horrifiée à je veux dire
l'idée qu'un journaliste
un journaliste du washington post puisse
entrer dans le consulat de son propre
pays pour y être brutalement assassiné
et démembré en avoir littéralement rien
fait de plus que critiquer son propre
gouvernement pour avoir voulu dire la
vérité à ceux qui sont au pouvoir et
s'être déjà exilés pour le faire entrer
dans ce consulat où il venait chercher
des papiers pour son mariage qui pour
épouser la femme qu'il aimait en lisant
cette histoire en en obtenant les
détails les dessous de la sphère en
apprenons plus sur cris étaient déjà mal
si je me suis passionné à l'idée de
faire la lumière sur cette affaire de
raconter à l'écran cette histoire qui
n'avait pas sa place dans les
informations
l'histoire inconnu de jamal khashoggi
montrer qui était cet homme et l'impact
que son meurtre à icare vous exposiez
les mensonges et les machinations liés
au dopage en russie
daou ping avec ce film ne craignez vous
pas des pressions des autorités
saoudiennes de leur outil de relation
publique face à la réalisation d'un film
qui met le gouvernement saoudien sous le
feu des projecteurs pour se marrer
alors comme nous sommes sur rtl me pose
toujours ce genre de questions avez vous
peur de la russie avez vous peur des
saoudiens et ma réponse est non
parce que je me considère journalistes
je me considère comme quelqu'un qui
cherche à dire la vérité et je crois
aussi qu en tant qu'américains j'espère
que nous avons encore un semblant de
démocratie
speech et de liberté d'expression qui
permet de raconter les choses système de
checks and balances et un système de
contre-pouvoir qui permet de dire la
vérité mais mais je pense que le plus
important pour moi c'est que je sais
bien qu'il ya des dizaines de milliers
de personnes en arabie saoudite qui font
face à des violations des droits de
l'homme ce qui est arrivé à jamal
khashoggi ou ce qui est arrivé à omar
abdel aziz tout ce qui est présenté dans
le film n'en sont qu'un horrible exemple
si je peux consacrer mon temps et mon
travail à aider d'autres personnes
alors je considère que tout risque est
justifié donc je ne pense jamais
vraiment à ce genre de choses et je fais
mon travail je regarde vers l'avenir et
et j'avance je suis vraiment fier
d'avoir aidé homard ou d'avoir aidé at
his 5 ghz la fiancée de jamal à faire
son deuil ou d'avoir aidé le monde à
mieux comprendre un pays où les droits
de l'homme sont bafoués
bien évidemment le gouvernement saoudien
nie toute violation des droits de
l'homme
mais c'est un excellent film je l' ai vu
moi même et dans notre émission go in
drug nous aimons le journalisme
audacieux mais j'ai commencé à avoir
peur quand vous expliquer comment des
logiciels peuvent être installés sur nos
téléphones
nous savons qu edward snedden a reçu
l'asile à moscou pour ses révélations
sur la surveillance de masse on ne va
pas trop en dire bien sûr car on peut
voir tout cela dans le film logiciel
israéliens que les saoudiens auraient
utilisé ils peuvent nous envoyer un lien
là maintenant sur nos téléphones et
c'est tout dans votre film il est dit
qu'un lien de ce genre a été envoyé à
jeff besos l'homme le plus riche du
monde cruel
on a inclus ça dans le film pour la
raison suivante nous voyons qu'on
utilise de plus en plus d'outils de
piratage et de surveillance informatique
edouard snowdon nous a tous fait prendre
conscience ici aux etats-unis de ce que
notre gouvernement c'est la haine et ça
faisait
et voilà quelques années plus tard on
comprend qu'il y à des logiciels
développés par des entreprises privées
comme l'israëlien nso gros qui vend ses
outils de piratage au gouvernement
quelles que soient leurs intentions si
leur but est que ces outils sont même
beaucoup plus dangereux que ce que
snowdon a dévoilé sur l'année sa jeune
soeur bykov c'est parce que c'est un
outil ciblées et direct qui peut prendre
le contrôle de votre dispositif cndd la
salade et comme nous le voyons dans ce
dissident l'arabie saoudite à utiliser
cette technologie pour pirater le
téléphone d'omar abdul aziz le dissident
saoudien qui vit à montréal est
et le téléphone de jamal khashoggi et ce
piratage a sans doute été l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles une fois qu'ils
ont eu accès à leurs appareils
ils ont décidé de tuer jamal je mens le
piratage du téléphone de jeff moss
c'était de la pure et simple vengeance
parce qu'il possède le washington post
un journal qui travaillent dans les
cadres de la liberté de la presse de
jeff bezos ne contrôle pas le contenu
éditorial du washington post
mais dans l'arabie saoudite de mohamed
bin salman
si vous possédez un journal watan cela
signifie que vous contrôlez réellement
ce qui est écrit et dans ce cas mohammed
bin salman été contrarié que le
washington post couvre le meurtre de
jamal khashoggi alors il a fait piraté
le téléphone de jeff bezos ce pour lui
donner une leçon et divulguer sa
relation extra conjugale pourrait dire
qu'il n'y a tout de même pas beaucoup
d'articles anti amazon dans le
washington post
mais il faut dire que ce film ainsi que
certains des grands films qui parlent de
classe du pouvoir des personnes
vulnérables prise pour cible par les
puissants montre que même la personne la
plus riche du monde peut être prise pour
cible droit
il est très ironique que vaisseau soit
une victime ici si on met de côté tout
le tragique c'est la brutalité de la
sphère khashoggi vous pouvez être comme
jeff besos et en être victime j'estime
que l'argent chez le pouvoir semble ne
garantissent pas du tout que vous
pourrez éviter cela les victimes peuvent
être de toutes sortes
il peut être plus difficile d'avoir de
la compassion pour l'homme le plus riche
du monde parce qu'il a été piraté et que
sa relation a été rendu public mais à
mon avis la conclusion à en tirer n'est
pas celle là il faut se rendre compte du
pouvoir qu un agent étatique peu à voir
s'il a accès à nos vies ce que ce
dissident veut également montré c'est le
contrôle de l'arabie saoudite sur les
médias sociaux et la mesure dans
laquelle ils vont essayer de contrôler
le discours et l'opinion publique et
dans laquelle un régime autoritaire non
seulement supprime la vérité mais tente
de créer sa propre version de la vérité
pour subvertir la réalité je ne veux pas
que les gens pensent qu'il n'y a ni
catharsis ni espoir dans votre nouveau
film
parlez-moi des abeilles et des mouchards
les abeilles et les mouches sont
essentiellement synonyme au cours des
dernières années et l'arabie saoudite
ont compris qu'ils ne pouvaient
contrôler la sphère publique et les
médias sociaux
80% des saoudiens sont sur twitter parce
que c'est la seule plateforme où ils
peuvent aller pour voir un semblant de
liberté d'expression et c'est donc là
que l'arabie saoudite partagent des
informations donc mohamed ben salman et
ses mouches ont embauché des milliers et
des milliers de saoudiens pour créer de
faux compte twitter pro-gouvernementaux
essentiellement pour promouvoir le
discours de mohammed bin salman sur
twitter pour faire croire que toute
l'arabie saoudite l'approuvaient et si
quiconque poster un commentaire non
favorable envers mohamed bin salman
ces commentaires étaient envahis par les
mouches bat pour donner l'impression que
l'opinion de cette personne n'était pas
sincère
après tout l'arabie saoudite utilise
essentiellement les médias sociaux pour
les pirates et pour créer ces hashtag et
ses tendances soldes 10 et donc les
abeilles sont ce qu omar abdul aziz et
jamal khashoggi qualifié de contre armée
avez vous envoyé le film à joe biden
parce qu'il semble avoir changé d'avis
lors des primaires il disait que
mohammed bin salman devait payer pour ce
qui s'était passé
ce n'est plus cas désormais vous savez
il y a eu une période où j'ai été très
excité à l'idée que le film sorte à ce
moment-là urinaires pensons au fait
qu'il y avait une nouvelle
administration américaine cube hayden
avait déclaré publiquement
j'ai l'intention de demander des comptes
à l'arabie saoudite
je vais changer le discours
les premiers jours de son mandat ça
semblait être le cas il a bloqué une
vente d'armes de 500 millions des
dollars à l'arabie saoudite et aux
émirats arabes unis
pis il a condamné la guerre au yémen il
y avait un drapeau de paix offert à
l'occasion de la libération de lee jane
à la poule
la militante saoudienne pour les droits
de l'homme et puis bien sûr il a publié
le rapport de la cia sur le meurtre de
cash au guide
mais ce rapport prouve sans l'ombre d'un
doute
je veux dire on le savait déjà mais
maintenant le rapport le confirme tout
simplement que mohammed bin salman a
ordonné le meurtre de jamal khashoggi
ensuite il donne a refusé d'imposer des
sanctions ou une peine quelconque à
l'arabie saoudite
c'est ça c'est envoyé le message non
seulement à moi même ben salman mais aux
dictateurs du monde entier que le
meurtre sera tolérée évidemment by donne
dit que ce n'était pas le message mais
lui avez vous envoyé ce film nous avons
des gens dans notre équipe qui
travaillait à cela mais je ne sais pas
s'il l'a vu je sais qu hillary clinton
l'a vu parce qu'elle a assisté à notre
projection l'année dernière plusieurs
membres du congrès ont vu le film
j'espère que les dirigeants du monde
entier pas seulement byden verront ce
film car oui nous vivons à une époque où
les états unis ou encore ce genre
d'autorité pour créer un précédent
mais je pense aussi que ce devoir
devrait également incomber au royaume
uni à la france alors une clé à
l'allemagne et si emmanuel macron angela
merkel boris johnson et justin trudeau
et d'autres dirigeants disent nous
allons faire quelque chose à ce sujet
nous allons annoncer des sanctions
on se dit que nous avons un contrat de
vente d'armes très solide
le royaume uni continuent de vendre
des armes à l'arabie saoudite dans le
cadre de la guerre au yémen après la
pause on retrouve brian boyle le
réalisateur oscarisé de retour pour
poursuivre notre entretien avec le
réalisateur oscarisé brian fogle on
parle aujourd'hui de son nouveau film
nominé aux bafta the 'dissident' il est
un peu difficile de comprendre que jean
a spell apparaissent dans le film comme
une sorte de héros qui participent à la
dénonciation des abus saoudiens selon la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat elle a dirigé une prison
américaine en asie du sud est
des gens ont été torturés qu'est ce
qu'on peut croire sur parole la cia
selon laquelle khashoggi a été tué c'est
que tout cela a été orchestré par
mohamed bin salman alors que la cia a
une solide réputation avec ses
tentatives d'assassinât contre castro et
certaines réussi notamment celles visant
che guevara à mon avis cela montre à
quel point tout cela est compliqué et
les chinois
[Musique]
lorsque hillary clinton a publié un
tweet en faveur 2 au 'dissident' son
compte twitter a été immédiatement
inondé par des commentaires comme
qu'avez-vous fait ici et là et qu'avez
vous fait à bengazi ce genre de choses
il faut comprendre qu'il existe beaucoup
de nuances de gris en politique
internationale
donc je ne pense pas que l'argument
selon lequel la cia et derrière des
complots et organise des meurtres dément
le fait que jamal khashoggi est entré
dans le consulat de son propre pays et
qu'il a été horriblement assassiné
étrangler drogué découpé en morceaux à
la scie avant que son corps ne soit
ensuite brûlé dans un four peut voir ça
dans le film car de toute évidence les
services de renseignements turcs ont
coopéré avec vous sur le film ils ont
violé les protocoles internationaux pour
mettre l'ambassade sur écoute mais je
dois peut être contesté un élément vous
dites qu'au moins une initiative de
mohamed bête
a été affecté par ce meurtre le davos du
désert où les grandes entreprises
étaient censés célébrer l'avenir de
l'arabie saoudite seulement un an après
les faits jared kushner s'est rendu là
bas
larry fink le président de blackrock
credit suisse goldman sachs hsbc ils y
étaient tous en 2019
elles et ils ont tenu avec succès une
conférence virtuelle cette année là si
des dizaines de millions de personnes
sont menacées de mort selon le conseil
des droits de l'homme votre film peut-il
être un facteur supplémentaire exclu
pour que les choses sont déçus c'est là
que ça devient compliqué oui si et moins
idiot ce que nous voyons ce que vous
venez de mentionner sur le davos du
désert d'asthme craint cette conférence
d'investissement organisé par mohamed
bin salman dans les deux années qui ont
suivi le meurtre de cachot qui se sont
présentées toutes ces banques
d'investissement que ce soit goldman
sachs crédit suisse ou kpmg
vous savez où les kouchner les chefs de
gouvernement ou même comme nous l'avons
vu récemment l'ancien premier ministre
italien matteo renzi qui est allé en
arabie saoudite et à parler de nouvelle
renaissance on voit que l'argent
l'argent et les investissements continue
à prévaloir sur les droits de l'homme et
il en va de même pour la chine et pour
tant d'autres pays dans le monde où il
ya trop d'argent pour le négliger
lorsqu'il s'agit d'abus ou de meurtre
comme celui ci et ses entreprises au
gouvernement dans le cas de vente
d'armes ou d'accords commerciaux peu
importe son prêt à fermer les yeux à
cause des intérêts financiers
c'est donc un chemin très périlleux et
je n'y vois pas de solution facile même
avec le meurtre de jamal khashoggi
comme vous le voyez dans le film agnès
callamard la rapporteur spécial des
nations unies
si aujourd'hui est aussi à la tête
d'amnesty international présente son
rapport à l'onu
une enquête a été ouverte et puis la
faire a été close les nations unies
refusent de faire quoi que ce soit il ne
ne transmettent pas au conseil de
sécurité et à l'assemblée générale
ils disent juste ok les états membres de
l'onu nous font savoir que tout en étant
consterné ils ne feront rien parce que
des milliards ou même des trillions de
dollars sont en jeu entre les
investissements le pétrole tous ces
intérêts complexe c'est la réalité du
monde dans lequel nous vivons
merci merci de m'avoir invité
maintenant pour entendre l'autre partie
dans cette affaire nous retrouvons la
capitale saoudienne riyad pourparlers
avec le fondateur et président du comité
des relations saoudo américaine salman
al ansari salman merci d'être avec nous
alors qui faut-il croire
brian fogle à qui on vient de parler un
réalisateur qui a remporté un oscar
tawakkol karman lauréate du prix nobel
de la paix la cia ou mohammed bin salman
lui-même
pour ce qui est de savoir si ce dernier
était responsable du meurtre brutal du
journaliste jamal khashoggi merci
beaucoup de m'avoir invité
je pense que le cas de monsieur
khashoggi a été l'objet d'une
politisation sans précédent ces
dernières décennies alors même que le
rapport de la cia lui même n'a fourni
aucune preuve de l'implication du prince
héritier dans cette affaire d'assassinât
alors même que le système judiciaire
saoudien a rendu justice en punissant
ceux qui ont commis ce crime contre mu
se cache mobile et alors même que la
famille de cache aubry a fait part de
son soutien à la décision de justice
nous constatons toujours l'existence
d'une campagne médiatique contre le
royaume et ses dirigeants
pour moi cela montre une chose ils ne
sont pas intéressés par la justice wang
feng watch mais cherchent à ternir la
réputation du royaume par tous les
moyens
est ce que ce sont seulement les médias
je veux dire dans ce film 'dissident'
jean a spell célèbre pour être accusé de
torture il faut le dire en tant
qu'ancien chef de la cia est très
préoccupé et manifestement la société
américaine semble croire la cia elle dit
que moi m ben salman et la personne
derrière cette affaire de votre côté
comme je lé remarquez vous avait twitté
quelque chose sur john bolton qui aurait
affirmé que la bande fournies par les
services de renseignements turcs
n'impliquait pas mohamed bin salman
écouter les etats-unis et leurs médias
affiliés et les soi disant organisation
de défense des droits de l'homme devrait
selon moi faire des efforts pour faire
face aux problèmes internes de
violations des droits de l'homme aux
états unis j'estime que si réorienter
20% des efforts qu'ils déploient au
niveau international vers leurs affaires
intérieures
les états unis seraient en mesure de
devenir le phare de l'espérance en
matière de droits de l'homme n'oublions
pas que les états unis ont tué plus de
800 mille citoyens en irak et en
afghanistan
et n'oublions pas qu'ils ont torturé des
prisonniers en irak et qui continuent de
le faire à guantanamo en lieu et place
de cela ils préfèrent fuir leurs propres
problèmes en accusant ayant serment dans
les autres oui oui nous voulons que les
etats unis soient pragmatiques
rationnelle qu'ils appellent les choses
par leur nom
il ne politisent pas les droits de
l'homme à ce point vers riyad est
devenue la principale capitale de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
idéologiquement et techniquement à un
tel point que vous n'entendez plus
personne affirmé que le royaume soutient
le terrorisme
le royaume a même franchi une étape
supplémentaire en encourageant ses
alliés occidentaux à prendre une
position plus ferme contre la haine et
les coupes radicaux tels que les frères
musulmans qui opèrent librement dans
tous les pays occidentaux y compris en
europe et aux états unis
je me souviens d'un média d'extrême
gauche qui a qualifié l'arabie saoudite
d'islamophobe c'est comme si quelqu'un
avait dit que le vatican était anti
catholique comme certains l'ont fait au
cours de l'histoire mais attendait
qu'ils à financer l'état islamique
dahesh al-qaïda en syrie cet argent ne
provenait t-il pas vaguement d'arabie
saoudite ben sous ben rial c'est une
question très intéressante parce que
l'arabie saoudite a été accusé par qui
c'est l'iran qui nous a accusés de
soutenir l'état islamique
c'est le seul pays qui blâment l'arabie
saoudite pour cela et ont-ils attaquer
l'iran il n'y a eu qu'un seul incident
et il a peut-être été monté de toutes
pièces par le régime iranien lui-même
n'oublions pas le fait que les chefs des
opérations d'al qaïda réside à téhéran
il se trouve en iran
saif al-adel et d'autre l'idée que le
gouvernement iranien et comme vous le
savez le gouvernement iranien ni cela
ils ne peuvent pas le nier je pense que
c'est bien prouvé par différentes
parties en particulier par le
département du trésor des états unis
il a mentionné clairement dans plusieurs
de ces rapports depuis 2013 donc l'idée
que l'arabie saoudite soit lié de
quelque manière que ce soit à al-qaïda
ou à l'état islamique est ridicule
personne n'y croirait moins que vous ne
puissiez réellement faire confiance au
régime iranien
certains pourraient dire que l'arabie
saoudite tombent dans le piège des
puissances avec lequel elle cherchait
des alliances dans le piège de
l'impérialisme oui je veux dire sur ce
film
ce dissident tu parles de la façon dont
l'arabie saoudite traite les
journalistes comme les anciens rois du
désert traiter les gens qui leur disait
les choses qu'ils voulaient entendre
[Musique]
moi je vous devez
les être au courant de ce que son
l'orientalisme et le racisme
pourquoi l'arabie saoudite ne réaliste
elle pas qu'elle devrait se rapprocher
de l'iran et qu'un monde musulman unis
seraient beaucoup plus fort qu un monde
où l'arabie saoudite se retrouve tout
simplement accusé d'être un état
assassin schosteck est atroce mais
croyez moi
l'arabie saoudite a toujours tendu la
main aux iraniens c'est notre voisin
personne ne peut nier que l'iran est une
belle histoire pierrot faut qu il a
apporté beaucoup à l'humanité mais le
régime iranien lui-même a
malheureusement saboter le peuple
iranien
je parle là de dizaines de milices en
syrie et du hezbollah
pékin qui est le principal sponsor du
terrorisme le plus grand groupe
terroriste au monde
mais le hezbollah est un parti politique
au liban l'irak et la syrie ont invité
ses unités iranienne intervenir
est ce difficile de mener une campagne
en faveur de l'arabie saoudite en ce
moment où se trouve le prince al-walid
ben talal al saoud
il possède des parts dans aol time
warner et y est juif ali and brothers et
il a son propre groupe
où est il que fait mohamed bin salman
avec tous ces gens ça vous dire favori
des américains mohammed ben nayef cette
histoire avec des rançons de 11
milliards est elle vraie adacore laissez
moi vous dire quelque chose je serai
très franc avec vous en tant que citoyen
saoudien
j'avoue que le royaume de l'arabie
saoudite n'a pas fait assez pour
raconter sa propre histoire à qui que ce
soit nous avons une très mauvaise
stratégie commerciale pour ce qui est de
raconter notre histoire au monde mais
nous ne devons pas oublier le fait que
les états unis ont une grande
responsabilité parce que ce sont eux qui
ont ouvert les portes de l'enfer au
moyen-orient après avoir envahi l'irak
et l'avoir livré au régime iranien sur
un plateau d'argent
malheureusement nous voyons en ce moment
que l'administration actuelle fait la
même chose en adoptant une politique
d'apaisement à l'égard de l'iran et
cette politique entraînera plus
d'instabilité dans la région et attrapes
le monde cela doit changer ça ne fait
aucun doute les états unis et l'iran nie
avoir soutenu le terrorisme
ils affirment qu'ils s'y oppose mais
rapidement et vous est certainement
pardonner certaines des sociétés de
relations publiques ici à londres
s'ils ont obtenu les gros contrat
saoudien mais comment vendez-vous la
guerre au yémen à la communauté
internationale et bien alors voilà la
guerre au yémen ne se déroule pas entre
le gouvernement de l'arabie saoudite et
le yémen comme cela a été présenté le
gouvernement légitime du yémen a demandé
à l'arabie saoudite et à la coalition
d'intervenir parce qu'un groupe une
milice liés à l'iran a pris le contrôle
de sanaa la capitale et de tout le pays
et devinez quoi avec la résolution 22-16
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
a été initié un accord c'est une
opération tout à fait légal l'égal d'un
point de vue international visant à
aider le gouvernement légitime le
yéménite et à le remettre à sa place
et heureusement à l'heure actuelle entre
75 à 80% des ter yéménites doivent être
libérés heureusement le royaume avec ses
alliés y compris les états unis ont
réprimé al qaïda dans la péninsule
arabique au yémen
ils les ont complètement éradiquée
heureusement nous assistons à la mise en
place d'une aide humanitaire de l'onu et
du royaume d'arabie saoudite qui est le
plus gros contributeur ayant versé plus
de 14 milliards de dollars lors de la
crise humanitaire au yémen
nous constatons ces choses là mais les
guerres sont difficiles vous pouvez
toujours commencer une guerre facilement
mais il est toujours difficile d'y
mettre fin c'est la réalité de la vie
c'est ce qui est arrivé aux états unis
en afghanistan et en irak et dans tant
de pays différents
ce qu'on voit ici c'est que le royaume
prône une solution politique par tous
les moyens
ils font de leur mieux avec martin
griffith
l'envoyé spécial de l'onu pour le yémen
parce que téhéran mène le bal
avec ses milices ce qui inclut les
houthis d'accord vous pouvez regarder
notre couverture de la crise au yémen
sur notre chaîne youtube salman al
ansari
merci
[Musique]
m